foreign
good morning and welcome to today's
press conference my name is Mia Robson
from the Canadian press and I'll be
moderating today today we have with us
Dr Supriya Sharma the chief medical
advisor at Health Canada Dr Howard new
the deputy chief Public Health officer
at the public health agency of Canada
and Dr Matthew Tunis the executive
secretary to the National advisory
committee on immunization so I will have
about an hour-ish up to an hour for uh
statements and questions we'll start in
the room if you are on zoom and would
like to ask a question please use the
raise hand function thank you
good morning good afternoon thank you
for joining us today I'm here to talk to
you about health Canada's authorization
of the Pfizer biontech bivalent covid-19
vaccine booster for people 12 years of
age and older this adopted vaccine
targets the original SARS cov2 virus as
well as Omicron for this reason it is
called a bivalent vaccine vaccines are
often adapted to better match
circulating variants to provide broader
protection against them this particular
vaccine contains mRNA from both the
original SARS cov2 virus and mRNA from
the Omicron ba4 and ba5 subvariants this
is the second bivalent covid-19 vaccine
authorized by Health Canada on September
2nd we authorized moderna's ba1 bivalent
booster for people 18 years of age and
older both of these vaccines will
produce a strong immune response and are
expected to provide improved protection
against Omicron and its submariants
circulating in Canada
Health Canada received Pfizer biotech
submission for this vaccine on September
2nd and the submission included safety
and immune response data from Pfizer
biotech's clinical trial for its Omicron
ba1 adopted bivalent vaccine as well as
pre-clinical and Manufacturing data
about the Omicron ba4 ba5 adopted
bivalent vaccine
Health Canada has extensive experience
with strain changes for annual influenza
vaccines and for this review Health
Canada use similar principles and
processes
pre-clinical data obtained from the
animal studies showed that a booster
dose of the ba4 ba5valent vaccine
triggered a strong immune response
against Omicron subvariance ba1 ba2 ba4
and ba5 as well as the original strain
of the virus
as part of our review Health Canada also
considered data on the safety and
effectiveness of the original Pfizer
biotech covid-19 vaccine which has been
safely administered to millions of
people in Canada and around the world
the vaccine safety profile is expected
to be comparable to that of the original
covid-19 vaccines for which a large
amount of data is available
it's worth noting as well that in the
U.S nearly 5 million doses of this new
Pfizer biotech bivalent vaccine have
already been administered and no new
safety signals have emerged
as it does with all Health Products
Health Canada will monitor emerging real
world safety and Effectiveness data on
the vaccine and will take immediate
regulatory action if any concerns arise
it's important to remember that
vaccination continues to be one of the
most effective tools that we have
available to protect against covet 19.
evidence shows that all mRNA covid-19
vaccines authorized for use in Canada
continue to be very effective at
preventing severe illness
hospitalization and death from covid-19
regardless of variant
keeping up to date with your covid-19
vaccines including getting your booster
doses as recommended will help protect
you and your loved ones against serious
illness and other complications from
covid-19 infection
now that the vaccine is authorized I'm
sure everyone is anxious to hear how it
will be used and Dr new will be
providing an update thank you merci
and now in French
for people aged 12 years and older this
adopted vaccine targets the original
Soros cov2 virus as well as the Omicron
environment variant for this reason it
is called a bivalent vaccine
vaccines are often better adapted to
match circulating variants
broader protection against them
this particular vaccine contains mRNA
from both the original SARS cov2 virus
and mRNA from the Omicron da4 and ba5
subvariants this is the second bivalent
covid-19 vaccine off authorized by
Health Canada on September 2nd we
authorized modernist ba1 bivalent
booster for people
years of age or older
both of these vaccines will produce a
strong immune response and are expected
to provide improved protection against
Omicron and its subvariance circulating
in Canada Health Canada received
submission for this vaccine on September
2nd the submission included safety and
immune response data from Pfizer
biontek's clinical trial foreign vaccine
clinical and Manufacturing data about
the Omicron ba4 ba5 adapted bivalent
vaccine Health Canada has extensive
experience with strain changes for
annual influenza vaccines for this
review Health Canada to use similar
principles and processes pre-clinical
data obtained from animal studies showed
that a booster dose of the ba4 ba5
bivalent vaccine triggered a strong
immune response against Omicron
subarians ba1 ba2 ba4 and ba5 as well as
against the original strain of the virus
as part of our review of Health Canada
also considered data on the safety and
effectiveness of the original Pfizer
biontech covid-19 vaccine which has been
safely administered to millions of
people in Canada and around the world
this vaccine's safety profile is
expected to be comparable to that of the
original covid-19 vaccines for which a
large amount of data is available
it's worth noting as well that in the
United States nearly 5 million doses of
this new Pfizer Bion Tech bivalent
vaccine have already been administered
and no safety signals have been
identified
as it does with all Health Products
Health Canada will monitor emerging real
world safety and Effectiveness and data
on the vaccine and will take immediate
regulatory action if any concerns arise
it's important to remember that
vaccination continues to be one of the
most effective tools we have available
to protect against covet 19.
evidence shows that all mRNA covid-19
vaccines authorized for use in Canada
continue to be very effective at
preventing severe illness
hospitalization and death from covid-19
regardless of variant
keeping up to date with your covid-19
vaccines including getting your booster
doses as recommended will help protect
you and your loved ones against serious
illness and other complications from
covid-19 infection now that the vaccine
is authorized I'm sure everyone is
anxious to hear how it will be used
Dr new will be providing an update
thank you
good morning good afternoon
today the public health agency of Canada
released updated guidance on Fall
boosters from the national advisory
committee on immunization or nasty
this update reflects Health Canada's
authorization of a second bivalent
covid-19 vaccine the Pfizer biontech
komarnati ba4 and ba5 vaccine nasty
recommends that people 12 years of age
or over who are eligible to get a
booster this fall receive a bivalent
Omicron targeting vaccine both of the
bivalent vaccines authorize for use in
Canada provide good protection against
Omicron
as vaccination continues to be one of
the most effective ways to protect
against serious illness but can Wane
over time is important for everyone to
stay up to date with covid-19
vaccinations if it has been six months
or more since your last vaccine dose or
covid-19 infection it is time to get
another dose
this is especially important if you are
65 years of age or older or have medical
conditions that place you at high risk
for severe illness from covet 19.
I am pleased to share that Canada will
have enough supply of the Omicron
targeting bivalent vaccines to cover the
anticipated demand for fall boosters I
know that some of you have already
received an original mRNA vaccine for
your fall booster evidence continues to
show that original mRNA vaccines provide
good protection against serious illness
and hospitalization including from
Omicron infection
if you recently received an original
mRNA vaccine for your fall booster you
do not need to receive a bivalent
Omicron targeting booster at this time
additionally as flu season approaches I
would also like to take this opportunity
to remind people in Canada to get a
seasonal influenza vaccine as soon as
they become available it is safe to
receive both the flu and covid-19
vaccines at the same time
vaccination is important this fall
especially if you are at high risk for
severe illness staying up to date on
your covid-19 vaccine and getting a
seasonal flu vaccine will give you the
best protection please contact your
local public health authority or
Province or territory to book a
vaccination appointment in your area
it is time to take action this fall stay
healthy by getting vaccinated
health agency of Canada updated guidance
from the national advisory committee on
immunization the NACI this update
reflection
authorization vaccine
um
to cover the anticipated demand for fall
boosters
I know that some of you have already
received an original mRNA vaccine for
your phone
evidence continues to show that original
mRNA vaccines
provide good protection against serious
illness and hospitalization okay
including from Omicron infection
at this time
I would also like to take this
opportunity to remind people in Canada
to get a seasonal influenza vaccine as
soon as they become available it is safe
to receive both the flu and covid-19
vaccines at the same time
vaccination is important
especially if you are at higher risk for
severe illness
staying up to date on your covid-19
vaccine and getting a seasonal flu
vaccine will give you the best
protection
please contact your local public health
authority or Province or territory
a vaccination appointment in your area
it is
stay healthy by getting vaccinated thank
you thank you
foreign
with Emily Bergeron from LA Press
Canadian
yes hello
the last time there were recommendations
it was only in certain cases
if they had certain specific health
conditions in this instance what are the
recommendations is it the same thing
you emphasize yeah people who have
already had a booster this fall do not
need to return and get another booster
with a bivalent vaccine are you
concerned that there will be a rush or a
certain number of people coming forward
get another dose right away in order to
have a bivalent vaccine this time around
to my mind
less than six months ago it's not
necessary to go back for another booster
at the criteria for the vaccination
programs a given Province or territory
and also taking into account
circumstances
region and also individual circumstances
for a given patient I think it is
possible
talk to a healthcare provider according
to the criteria of our vaccination
program for the province and territory
you might not have a simple assistant
NACI recommends a six-month wait but
taking into account other considerations
would be possible to offer another dose
after three months I could also add to
that Dr new
um in in the report excuse me uh the
committee also outlines that the
expectation is not that there would be a
routine booster program offered every
three months but although in some
exceptional circumstances you know
individuals may seek that but uh that's
not the routine expectation going
forward so we'll continue to see how the
product environment evolves and how the
epidemiology evolves but
um to dispel that myth there there's not
an expectation that it'll be a routine
three-month cycle
I'm going to take the moderator's
privilege and ask questions from my spot
over here uh for the for now
um I'm just curious there was a lot of
confusion when we approved the moderna
ba1 about why we were doing that and not
the ba4 when that was being approved in
the United States and I think a lot of
people are confused about which one to
get what's the effectiveness of both can
you talk a little bit like sort of
telling people if they have a choice or
if they don't have a choice if they
should just get still the vaccine that's
offered to them that's available
sure I mean I think it's a broader
question about like what to do with this
at this stage so I think it the factors
in terms of deciding
um what dose is right for you and when
really haven't changed so there's really
four things one is when is the last time
you had a dose of vaccine either your
last booster your last vaccination
um did you have covet and if so when was
that
what are your own personal I'll call
them biological risk factors you know
age do you have other illnesses and then
what are your exposure sort of risks um
and that includes you know where you're
working or um your environment or if you
are going to be undertaking activities
that potentially put you at a an
increased risk like travel or
um or you know weddings or something
you're doing in indoors so those factors
are all the things that we would
consider I think our general message is
if you are six months post any vaccine
and covid illness then you should get
your bivalent vaccine you should get
that booster and that'll help you in
terms of serious illness protection but
it'll also give you some protection
especially in the short term against
potentially getting infected with covid
there does not seem to be a significant
difference between the ba1 moderna and
the ba45 Pfizer now they're very similar
they're both Omicron by valence they
will both broaden your immune protection
moderna has a slightly increased dose
compared to Pfizer it might be a bit
better against ba1 and ones and viruses
that look like ba1 compared to the
Pfizer ones B the Pfizer one might be a
bit better against four or five and the
ones that look like that but basically
when we're looking at the animal studies
the immune response for those ba1
bivalent and the ba4 bivalent when we
looked at moderna was basically the same
so I can understand people who are
having sort of conditions but it's
basically if you're six months out get
your bivalent get whatever bivalent you
can get if you are uh three months out
from a dose of vaccine or uh or
um covet illness then consider getting
the bivalent and again that will depend
on your individual biological risk
factors and what you might be doing in
the next in the next while we are
starting to see an increase in cases we
are heading into the fall season there's
a lot of gatherings and festivals that
are happening as well so we know that
there's going to be increasing
circulating virus so again if you're in
that time period if you are less than
three months I would not advise you at
this point in time to get a booster and
it's not because of a safety reason but
because the effectiveness of that
booster is likely not going to be as
good as if you got it after three months
so that's kind of the the advice that we
would be giving now
yeah so I'll just reach certainly from a
public health perspective you they're
both you know Omicron containing uh you
know sort of a variant of vaccines and
therefore uh certainly if you go out I
think whatever is offered to you is
certainly what's available at the local
level when you go for your appointment
to get the a bivalent vaccine booster I
would take whatever's offered
I'm also curious I believe that Pfizer
had also submitted a ba1 bivalent
vaccine I don't think that one's been
approved has that been dropped now are
we still considering it and I sort of
double double barreling my question
um do we feel like we've sort of caught
up to the variance now with the ba45
since those are the dominant variants
circulating
yes we did uh we did we do have a Pfizer
ba1 bivalent under review and it was
basically completed in terms of the
health Canada portion of the review
there's a lot of activities that go into
the finalization of a review at the end
in terms of labeling and other
administrative sort of things Pfizer at
this point in time said they could
basically support one or the other and
we looked at which one would likely be
the one that would have the most uptake
and that was four or five just to say
that all the data that we looked at for
the ba1 bivalent is something that we
actually incorporated into and was part
of the supporting and data for the ba455
valence so now that we've finished the
va45 valent and once that gets rolled
out we'll go back and complete the ba1
as well but there's a question about how
much interest there will be um in terms
of uptake on that and sorry your second
part of the question was just have we
sort of caught up to the variants
um I think it's we're in an interesting
kind of place in the pandemic where we
haven't been before there's a bit of a
variant soup out there it's there's lots
of different ones it's still a little
bit uncertain which one might emerge I
think you know the vaccines that we have
now protect us very well against the
circulating variants that we currently
have there is some evidence that at
least some of the top candidates were
the ones that might emerge in the next
wave would be covered by these vaccines
but I think it's you know we're still
learning as we go with the pandemic and
we're seeing still a lot of as we said
mutations and variants come out so it's
a little bit challenging to to see what
the future holds but certainly Omicron
has been the one that has had probably
the most staying power of all the
different groups of variants and the
ones that were emerging seem to be in
that area and so that's why the bivalent
Omicron bivalence vaccines as boosters
are likely to offer better protection
than the originals and I I could add a
little bit to that as well from the
perspective of um of nasty and the
advice they provided today
they in terms of immunization strategy
the committee is clear that the goal of
this fall program and using by villain
boosters going forward is to increase
the breadth of the immune response not
necessarily to try and get the closest
match to the strain of today or the you
know the best fit the goal is to
increase that bread then we know that
both the ba1 and ba5 are Omicron
variants and Omicron is very distinct
from the original strain of the virus so
that stretches the immune response
provides that breadth and that diversity
that should hold us in good stead going
forward so that's a bit of their
perspective around the strategy of the
program for the fall
thank you so we'll now go uh to zoom if
you have a question on Zoom please use
the raise hand function and we'll start
with Glenn McGregor from CTV
hi thanks for taking a call um
the drive to get more people booster
shots has not been a rip roaring success
I think the last time I checked you were
somewhere around 15 for people
forgetting their second booster and now
you're asking people to get uh another
one in some cases this supposed to be
people's fifth shot
um do you have a projection of how many
people are actually going to get this
this shot
it's tough to you maybe I can I can
respond to your question you know
certainly uh as we've gone through this
pandemic we're always learning in terms
of not just from the scientific
perspective in terms of you know what
vaccines uh work you know in the
formulation but also in terms of
Behavioral Science so I think what
you're getting at is in terms of uh you
know vaccine confidence and vaccine
uptake and in small part also maybe some
issues about vaccine hesitancy so we're
very alive to that we have lots of uh
experts behind the scenes uh looking at
uh uh you know what different ways or
what ways we can reinforce in terms of
uh giving the right information and not
just to you know the average Canadian to
be quite honest but also to a health
care providers Community leaders are
using multiple platforms so that people
at the end of the day can make hopefully
an informed decision uh as to why it is
important and it's it's good to keep up
with your vaccination so uh that's all I
can say and you know the modeling I
think you know in some ways you know you
can take sort of the here and now but as
we continue with the reference to
improve vaccine confidence to a variety
of means we certainly anticipate that we
will increase and improve uptake
but are you not seeing a different
problem than vaccine hesitancy or lack
of confidence in the people who are
nervous about getting vaccines initially
you're now seeing people who have had
vaccines
the first two shots and maybe an
additional booster but are now saying
I'm not going to go in there for a fifth
that's a different kind of kind of
problem I'm wondering how you're going
to address what looks to be more like
vaccine fatigue rather than hesitancy
yeah it's opportunity you're right
that's a good point in terms of you
mentioned vaccine fatigue and and you're
right in the early days uh certainly
when the first vaccines came out uh
certainly uh well everyone was thinking
said okay let's say you know the term
fully vaccinated or getting sort of the
two doses of a primary series was the
way to go and then we were thinking
about you know uh sort of herd immunity
with baby to be quite honest at the time
not not knowing initially what the sort
of the longer protection might be now
we're all learning and the fact is that
certainly uh what we've seen from the
worldwide experience as well as here in
Canada is that the immunity wanes was
time and that that's that's you know
natural normal for for uh many vaccines
and infected diseases so now
with the latest evidence we have we
recognize that it is about you know six
months being the limit and I think we're
now changing you know in terms of uh uh
you know updating informing Canadians
that hey you know in some ways I'm not
saying it's a Perfect Analogy again but
uh take the case of influenza vaccine I
think people have now been socialized
and you know sort of a are aware that
hey you know influence a vaccine it's
not sort of a one and done kind of deal
in terms of getting vaccinated that you
need to do it on a regular basis in the
case of influenza it's sort of an annual
uh uh you know basis you know more into
the fall and we just mentioned about
getting your flu vaccine this fall as we
head into the winter respiratory season
and I I can anticipate that uh you know
our our sort of Education or you know
you know awareness campaigns for for uh
covid-19 vaccines that may uh uh be
aiming the same same direction saying
that you know we don't know what the the
Rhythm might be or the sort of what a
regular uh sort of a getting updated in
terms of a covid-19 vaccine uh will be
uh based obviously on sort of the ever
evolved having a you know evolution of
the virus and mutations but I think
that's where I where we're heading I
think it is uh by and large will get
that so you could say yes there is
vaccine fatigue in terms of what we've
been through for the past two years but
I think as uh we try to head back to uh
what we might call a more normal uh or
New Normal in terms of how we manage uh
covid-19 moving forward uh my my uh
anticipation uh hope is that people
recognize that compared to many other
infectious diseases we've learned a lot
from covid-19 and maybe the way uh for
the future for vaccination is that there
is this idea that there there needs to
be sort of a regular sort of a a rhythm
or getting uh you know up to or keeping
up to date with your your covid-19
vaccine
okay we'll next go to Olivier Faron
Boise from tevea
rule yes hello um
and how the company was able to
demonstrate the added value of this
vaccine
[Music]
to carry further forward so you know if
I understood the question it was about
the increased protection of the
increased effectiveness of this new
bivalent product and oh it'll defer to
Dr Sharma but you know the comments what
was outlined from the from nasty in the
report and their analysis is that
um it
most of these assays were antibody
assays and so you do see increased
neutralizing ability to neutralize
Omicron variants in the bivalent
products
can't make direct comparisons between
the ba1 or the ba5 products because they
are you know were studied differently
different assays in different
environments but there are not clinical
Effectiveness data that would be able to
give us a percentage of how much more
protective we expect ba5 to be than the
boosters that came before but all the
indications from the laboratory assays
that were studied suggest that there
will there would be some increased
neutralizing ability of the antibodies
and then we would assume some increased
protective ability but Dr Sharma did you
want to add anything on that so the way
that we do the these types of bivalence
studies is that you look at the
comparison between the new vaccine and
you compare it with the original sort of
strain and so what they have to be able
to demonstrate is that so if it's a ba1
vaccine that they actually have a better
immune boost than the original against
ba1 if it's a ba45 they need to have a
better immune boost compared to those
viruses than the original and so this
ba45 showed an increased level of what
we call neutralizing antibodies so those
antibodies that come up right after you
have your vaccination against ba2 ba4
and ba5 they're about the same against
ba1 and there was a significant response
it's difficult to actually say a number
better than the original because again
these are animal studies and they are
just looking at neutralizing antibodies
and there's a whole other
a part of the immune system that gives
you sort of more lasting immunity but
really that's what it showed is that
there was a good immune response and it
was better against these Omicron
variants than it was compared to the
original and just to say that the
bivalent vaccine as a reminder is
bivalent so by for two and it has both
the original strain as well as the
Omicron specific ba4 ba5 for the modern
one it has both the original strain as
well as the the vaccine against the A1
we merci
um yes thank you
I would like to hear you on
an approach of another country Denmark
posters for people under age 50. and no
longer offers vaccination for people
under 18. because in both cases
they're less at risk to develop serious
illness I was wondering how you can
explain the difference that exist
between
um approach of a country such as Canada
and Denmark
also turn to doctor doing this but
actually each country has its own
evaluation evaluation committee and the
committee
National advisory committee on
immunization
recommendations based on scientific
probative data but also from Canada and
the Canadian context I cannot speak to
what is this
discussions or what we feel is happening
in Denmark but here in Canada
we do what's best for Canadians but now
I'll turn to Dr Tunis um
yeah I mean I think Dr new captured it
well every country has a unique context
and so we know that the immunization
program decisions that are made by
different countries would consider both
the products that are available to them
and authorized in those countries and
also the you know the history of the the
pandemic to date in that country too so
levels of zero prevalence how many
people have already been infected those
can also factor into thinking at times
and we do see a diversity of approaches
across the world right now with fall
booster campaigns for example in the U.S
they are are using largely the ba5
boosters in the UK they're using largely
ba1 and original and in Canada and
Germany you're seeing the bivalent
products be preferred overall so we do
see a diversity of approaches and that's
not unusual because there are so many
factors that would go into any decision
making for any given country which as I
mentioned include the epidemiology the
the context you know the vaccine uptake
in vaccine history in that country tree
for this program so far so it's it's
really hard to draw direct comparisons
but what's outlined in the latest expert
advice is that yes in fact we do still
see hospitalization rates and disease
rates among populations under 50 for
example and so Nessie does recommend
that boosters may be offered for those
12 to 64
with the the bivalent product so it uh
it yeah it's we're going to continue
seeing diversities across the world and
we shouldn't be expecting to see Harmony
we we don't expect that with most
immunization programs every country has
a unique context
we're going to come back to the room
Stephanie Levitz from the Toronto Star
good morning um Dr Sharma I wonder if I
could ask you about something else and
that's the current shortage of infant um
Motrin Tylenol ibuprofen products and if
you're able at all to sort of address
the steps that Health Canada seems to be
taking to deal with that shortage and
what advice um perhaps you or Dr new
have for parents you know we have
anecdotes of people using expired
products for their children trying to
tweak adult products to fit an infant
formulation so I was hoping you could
address that
sure so in terms of the the shortage
that we're seeing or people are seeing
uh difficulties obtaining both the
acetaminophen and the ibuprofen products
for children this has been something
that's been going on since the summer
and just to give you a bit of the the
background what happened was that there
was an increase in that utilization over
the summer
um these are seasonal products
manufacturers produce them in certain
quantities and then there tends to be an
uptick in in the fall sort of season
usually utilization is lower in the
summer it was increased potentially
because of some increase in viral
illnesses but there was also a lot of
attention to the issue and we could see
an increase in uptake when that
attention was there and I think we all
lived through the beginning parts of the
pandemic when you know when there was
runs on toilet paper for example so I
think there is a certain extent there's
some Panic buying there and I can
understand that from a parental point of
view they want to make sure that they
have products available to treat fever
and pain so but what we've done is that
we've worked with manufacturers there's
the manufacturers that are now
manufacturing it double or triple what
their normal volumes would be for Canada
at this point in time we're exploring
other options whether or not there are
other sources other countries that might
have product available there tends to be
an overall a bit of a tightness in the
system across across the board but we're
looking at that as well but the other
part is that it we really want to make
sure that people are only getting
medication buying medication when they
need it I know that there's a tendency
to make sure that they have have
medication there just in case but it's
it's bleeding as we said is to some
Panic buying out there and when we look
at the buying in Canada compared to
other countries that are very similar so
that have similar patterns in terms of
viral
illnesses going up Canada seems to be
using or buying more of the product
right now so I think part of it is just
to say we don't panic there is more
product coming in as we said
manufacturers have increased their
production we expect to get more product
in especially for hospitals over the
next little while but also in the
community so that's the first part of it
then the second part of it is in terms
of advice I think first of all fevers as
a symptom as a symptom of a usually an
infection in children it's usually viral
it's usually harmless so I think it's
one part of it is that not all fevers
necessarily need to be treated if you
have a child that's three months of age
and younger then that's something that
you should be concerned about you should
see a healthcare practitioner if you
have a fever that's very high that's
persistent you may want to see your
health care practitioner but you don't
necessarily have to treat it there are
alternatives you know whether it's cold
compresses or for pain you can use warm
baths and things there's other things
that you can do as well but also you
know as we just go back to it is to not
not purchase products from sources that
are not credible so online you know only
from credible sources we would recommend
against using expired products and it's
not because you know automatically on
the day after the expiry that it won't
work or it's dangerous but we just don't
have data to support how stable those
products are in the longer term if you
are using adult preparations and and you
know maybe using the powders and putting
it in Jam or yogurt or something just be
very careful about the dosing especially
for acetaminophen because it's very easy
to overdose on acetaminophen and cause
liver injury especially in younger
children more so with acetaminophen with
ibuprofen so if you're doing any of that
then I would consult a pharmacist to
make sure that that calculation is being
done appropriately you can also go to
compounding pharmacies and they will be
able to make up preparations it may not
be exactly the same flavor but they can
compound specific doses they have a
specific shelf life as well so there's
lots of things that can be done as well
but I think the major point is that we
just need to be very careful about sort
of the panic buying at this point in
time and as again totally understand the
anxiety of having a screaming child in
the middle of the night with fever or
pain but I think this is when we have to
again look collectively at that supply
and and it is there it is coming in
there are alternatives and we will get
through this next period of time if we
all if we all work together
yep it's Dr new the only thing I would
add to what Dr Sherman has said is that
you know obviously these medications
continue to be uh over the counter I
think there was some maybe some
misunderstandings or so uh previous
state that had to be by prescription so
it's still over the counter and and
really you know in terms of a best
practice uh you know if if a parent uh
is wondering not sure what to do I think
really as Dr Sherman indicated speak to
healthcare professional because in terms
of uh the actual individual context what
could or should be done to obviously
manage be it pain or fever for for our
child is best managed by by speaking to
someone who actually uh can give you the
best advice on the ground
and and then just as a follow-up some
um people have suggested that one of the
ways we could alleviate the shortages to
allow for the importation of foreign
language labeled products similar to
what's been done in other situations in
the past is that something you're
actively exploring
um why or why not so that Avenue is
already open so I know I've heard some
of the discussions about having a new
framework but the Food and Drugs Act and
the regulations already allow for
critical medications to be to to come in
we also have something that's called
compliance and enforcement discretion so
we can bring in product
um obviously we want to make sure that
the product is as close to a product
that's already authorized either in
Canada or elsewhere and that it's
reliable and it's safe and it's
effective and it's high of high quality
and then if a foreign product is coming
in we want to make sure that there is a
provision to have some sort of
information around directions for use
and safety information in both official
languages and there's a variety of
different ways to do that so that's an
Avenue that's already open we've spoken
to manufacturers about the possibility
of using that pathway it's a matter of
having Supply that they can then provide
but there's nothing there's no barriers
from a regulatory perspective in terms
of bringing foreign foreign product in
thank you
I think Emily Bergeron has another
question in the room
um yes thank you
um
do you have some idea at what time the
first doses of the new vaccine that was
approved today
at what point will it be available in
vaccine centers any pharmacies okay
thank you well what I can tell you now
one vaccine
there are 10.5 million doses in the
country now and if you want to talk
about the new Pfizer vaccine
we're expecting next week to have
deliveries of doses we expect that we
have a contractors
12.6 million doses
as the weeks go by will receive a
million Doses and in total is 12.6 and
between the two yeah I think it's enough
in the meantime to cover the expected
demand for booster doses thank you and I
have another question
not sure who said
that we don't yet know
um
foreign
to that um so you're right that in terms
of the immunization strategy
Nasi has recommended that we do not need
to be prepared for a routine every
three-month program and I think Dr new
previously commented that um everyone is
very eager to have a more predictable
cycle for kova 19 boosters and and
programs
doesn't seem like we are quite there yet
the the fall program is a step towards
some predictability but
it remains to be seen you know how the
epidemiology will unfold with new
variants Etc
generally it has been taking several
months from the launch of a new vaccine
to accumulate enough evidence to be able
to ascertain vaccine Effectiveness
estimates so to understand how well the
vaccine actually performs in the real
world has been taking somewhere between
two to four months generally after the
launch of those programs I would say
overall so far throughout the pandemic
so I think we could anticipate that
Within
several months we will start
understanding vaccine Effectiveness real
world evidence to see the performance of
the product
and then over time that can be monitored
and you know measured against the
emergence of new variants and all of
those considerations will have to factor
in we understand that the manufacturers
are continuing to consider what the
forward path for their products will be
and if they might generate new boosters
that's still a bit unclear so I think
there will be probably regulatory
Frameworks that will emerge and Dr
Sharma could maybe comment on that about
you know regulatory Frameworks around
future cycles for other booster products
but at this point we're a bit in a
weight in c space we are launching this
fall program and then we'll monitor over
time but we don't anticipate routine
every three months it's not a
sustainable immunization program model
it doesn't exist in any other areas and
it just doesn't seem like a realistic
program so although there are some
exceptional circumstances where these
shorter intervals may be necessary we're
going to be looking towards some kind of
a more sustainable approach and so nasty
has been clearing their advice on that
that we'll have to keep watching and
develop some more sustainable long-term
framework well as they say doctor in
potatoes thank you and perhaps I could
add something in French
and we have a lot more experiences with
other infectious diseases such as the
seasonal flu so I think we are still
learning and we continue to monitor the
evolution of the virus and of course in
the future we may find some pace for a
booster dose foreign
maybe it's a very short limit but the
general recommendation is at least if
it's six months for sure it's important
to receive a booster but in other
circumstances we might also offer a
bivalent vaccine as a booster of after
three months it's not a general policy
that everyone has to take advantage of
that thank you okay I think that
concludes today's conference thank you
very much